oh I did not work okay well I meant to
die in this endeavor wait I really do
want to charge into death okay you want
to take this Jeep here and just drive it
in and no that's not a good cheap
cerimon nevermind that did not good Jeep
you get it I'll be right behind let's go
face death just we'll go up to rock and
die there right marker yeah let's do
that
okay we'll join you soon sorry really
wish I wasn't running behind you but I
guess I'll just try to appreciate the
view for what it is
Thanks thank you fully decked out -
pants thank you ooh get in the car let's
go get [ __ ] you you drive let's go get
[ __ ]
I don't know death whatever the most
death yes aiya [ __ ] it yeah I'm sure
going full-speed in this this particular
vehicle will never end wait wait no I
trust my driver I trust him be good yeah
I just start shooting wildly to announce
our location
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
come on yeah that's offensive look out
there yeah I got a car guys want to get
in the car and us [ __ ] off
hey listen the right direction before I
died thanks Wade you're welcome if you
guys want a shotgun or maybe I had a
vest on me I don't even remember what I
had hey how's it going hey what's up
guys what's up let's get in the car I'm
here where we going we're too hot here
just honk so this is the first time we
got a drive over go to Georgia
go there yeah [ __ ] no well yeah do what
Jack says what what Oh red bread you got
it
so you're new in town right side right
side oh that ain't good
[Music]
battleship hey I killed support allows
it sure stating you think it was my
honking that announced us we could go
George poll shooting range kind of sucks
in my experience I don't know but we
could go out ruins and then go George
Boole I'm into that
okay race it go whoa is the ruins the
one in the Bayou or the one that looks
like ruins the flooded city that's not
good
no that's cool it's cool guys it's cool
it's cool it's fine I don't know what he
says he's happy when things are going
well alright okay I got a I got a scar
and a helmet and a bike a pack cool i'ma
try to rendezvous with you Bob what's
your shooting that Wade there's a bad
guy on this roof a bad guy or any of us
really worst um so one of them's over
here don't know where the other one is
I'm gonna move towards Wade then I'm
trying to get to a spot where I can help
you out mark oh man I'm almost dead it
came from southeast I think pretty sure
is behind me not on earth that's where
Jack is like why he's downstairs yeah in
the corner yeah I seen by this with him
I see him I got him whoops that was
super laggy but okay sorry I know I'll
be joining us soon in the afterlife here
anybody got a sody pop to top me off
yeah I got some heels for you market you
want some coming in the building with
you guys I'm gonna mourn over at a
friend a friend here I'll drop you some
of this and some of that just seal right
up there buddy monster and yeah that's
energy drink you [ __ ] remember him
dude I [ __ ] love guarana
alright I'm just gonna use all these
bandages if you go as demand go for it
we don't need them we don't get shot
like a [ __ ] Wow okay a bunch of excuses
and we don't do that [ __ ] this is this
is buttery smooth you know it is who
already got one bro dude what about
frozen mark III got a level one I like
to play a hard mode so where should we
go they're fillers I don't know
somewhere where Jack would feel really
bad that he's excluded from you should
go to George Paul I that's a valid point
that's where all shits go to Georgia
pole
you headed there yeah I'm headed I'm
heading out towards Georgia pool you
think you tell me you can't loop me in
on anything man I'm just trying to die
man that's what I'm out for it's just
reconnecting lovely up here is it fun no
I'm bored as [ __ ] if you look at all you
douche bags okay wait there's this wheat
rifle right here it's a it's an m4 16
weird though there's no ammo with it I
don't know what happened
shut up man damn God's watching no I
want you to watch bro are you doing this
one-handed right now hell yeah
I'm not even mad I'm just impressed I do
my life one-handed bro
whoa with that that's a thing buggy
buggy kill kill bugs over near me that's
a bike Oh like kill kill it's going
towards Georgia Pole do you guys
shooting still ye yeah okay vikas [ __ ]
yeah where'd he go yes
way up there did you get the gun Wade no
where was it it's [ __ ] marker god I'm
gonna take the sake here right here why
do I do anything for you right here Wade
what I said about listening from the
south from the south Wade from the south
from the south they hurt my level 3
helmet as a headshot yeah where is that
where is that person's I don't know
behind us in the ruins or something yeah
I think they are right like oh I see a
guy on foot 210 from me I can't I don't
have a shot on but he's on foot Heat
they're moving right now okay wave I'm
gonna move up I only saw one but it's
either a teammate of the guy whose bike
we [ __ ] up or it's another squad
dropping my decked-out shotgun here
shotgun or some five five six where'd
you go friends but they're to the south
south south of us moving moving to South
West yeah okay like trying to get up the
hill but I don't know where they went
I don't know where that shot came from
but I feel like this is not a good place
for me to be right now there's not a
floor hey
[Laughter]
go [ __ ] stand over there oh that's
scary start reading men on me it's brain
hallelujah it's raining me out there is
where people to marker on him and rock I
can't shoot over this wall from there
yeah I saw him on the right side but
he's probably maneuvering around to get
a better shot real close to us or big
rocks on that big rock they're always
moving up the hill right now
man I can't hit [ __ ] mark season look
what I choose he's moving now moving
again I have a frag I'm gonna he's got a
car come there he got it and his friend
was like I'm getting out [ __ ] you okay I
knocked out one of them um help yeah I'm
getting shot from the top of the hill I
see by that Bush I think it's really
bold that they put a report button in
every time you die report everyone yeah
I think there is more than one squad
that we're currently engaged with mm-hmm
that's the thing about squads it's like
it's so hard to fix go on my body if you
want to go out there I had two two two
two exes
Oh mark you could do it oh look at me
he's just prone in the grass or unless
he moved I popped below the hill this
see I don't know where you just saw him
wait you just saw him he's right there
yep nice hey what about the other one
their squad is gone then Yeah right
someone just smoked I think that was him
the guy that Wade killed those smokes
take a look like a few seconds to pop
okay oh that wasn't a smoke that was
this car dying no that was definitely a
smoke that was smoke okay I thought I
heard a smoke grenade b3 it was all yeah
oh my god I was spectating market when
you went to loot you like reach down and
pick something up and his body
disappeared did you pick up any heels by
chance I got a painkiller I'm gonna need
I had a first aid kit on my body there's
a bunch of five five six here to mark if
you need it if I didn't steal it you can
use I didn't take the first with the
bandages you guys are trying to watch
for anyone running up I feel like they
would have shot at you by now kiss
weights just been standing in the open
for a while go friends some chicken
dinner and stuff only 39 people left
only 37 for us to kill mark me a few
teams
you only need them all to kill each
other right here oh so there were two
squads or something or another don't
just leave oh they killed those guys
let's go I'd abandon these guys that's
kind of the wise thing to do if we had
seen to other squads we should have been
like let's let them kill each other
you bet there's someone in that building
check it out I bet this someone in that
building open
I think these doors are always open oh
oh it's a garage I see yeah that's uh
weight weights in there right now mark I
think I think I think it's glitter
he's not in there so if you really want
to throw a grenade like I guess you can
let him pretend I am so we can get out
of his system and not actually kill this
even me now aid the thing
no I'm cooking dinner please there's
another first aid kit you want it I've
got three and a medkit you go ahead my
favorite is when you go into the
building like this and then you open one
of these doors and there's just a dude
there with a shot surprise [ __ ]
hole is like my least favorite possible
circles I hate when this mountain is in
there mmm
so it's like king of the mountain what
do you got against mountain weights well
it sucks like the first one up there
because there's a hundred teams that
push and sucks if there's someone else
up there because they always target you
and then the other team comes up and
kills them and you maybe just be good
and kill them all yeah you're right
you're when you're right you're right
and you just need to get good wait I'm
sorry yeah you are in the sink oh I get
it
explain yeah what do you want to die on
top of the mountain or under the
mountain I don't know they get fun guys
come on
yeah make it good for the viewers me die
at both that's the challenge okay
alright wait what are you going for here
oh well we go to this building complex
and try fighting to hold a building okay
one death is as good as another in my
opinion here's where the awm on the
mountain just single-shot headshots us
both real quick on our way well I got a
level 2 helmet it's gonna be good right
yeah it can it's it's it's as good as -
it's the one I got off of that dead guy
do you know it's good if that happened
there was someone just laying in the
middle of a field and no one saw him
until they ran into it couldn't get past
it so are you suggesting we be the
people in the middle of the field or we
be the the inept people stumbling across
it well because people have feel we're
more like mountain take the mountain I
don't
that none dominate I see fire on the
mountain your gain yourself become the
mountain that was the law of the Thrones
reference we're not we're not gonna
throw or drag in or move it up we're
just gonna know Game of Thrones is about
dragons hell yeah booth drag me still
are you one of those people who hasn't
watched Game of Thrones well I have not
seen anything I might even see a
commercial for it Ethan Allen seen it
either do you think they're right above
us where where's a bow north where those
rocks are it stop this rock start by the
meadow see the guy walking off the
mountain right there right wait up to
the right I saw the tree yeah I see them
way to the right yeah that's the
motorcycle I won't pop that's a squad
they parked the motorcycle behind that
Ridge and our climbing up the mountain
should we shoot out there behind that
Ridge isn't that crate oh boy hey I see
a map Daman don't engage them they're
gonna give you the D mm what if we give
them the D I mean you could try but now
I'll follow we give each other the deep
not like you need but like the teams
that's what you meant wait love smart
[Music]
you're gonna go for the mountain well we
have to look at the circle I guess I
mean maybe we should like um the bullets
oh hey they're peeking over the top of
the ridge there at 60 from you mark the
very top of the mountain is it dude
where wait right there wait there we go
there was another one up to the right
from where that dude was also in that
little crack Gulin little anus sweet
little Mountain crack Oh Wade you're so
far ahead of me never gonna be very good
wait a secret stair seeing the [ __ ] out
of this all right
I don't know about no secret stairs so
I'm just gonna take this don't know why
there's that's a lot of holes that's so
close to you Wade yeah that's fun
oh I think I'm in trouble someone's
shooting from behind me run mark just
gonna die
for I'm a man oh boy I know if you guys
win I'm gonna be sad
I like God where is like Ted feet away
from all that murder we got just a few
wait
I'm Cup full-auto coming in maybe if I
can get up the goddamn Mountain
anyway now slowly surely maybe not
surely but slowly definitely what the
with the with the Trixie frag advantage
you should rush him Wade got a few hits
into him
get Otto to Autozone baby throw a
granade [ __ ] like bounce doubt that
dude says popped up and you turned and
look if you're like take this no no the
circle gotta move way yeah the circle
just forget me forget about me
carry on my memory I'm dead oh I was
like right there I enter the circle to
see wait yeah well I think that guy went
down god of course I chose that one
moment to pull my frag out stupid yeah I
think there's still more to your north
win on the other side of the ridge yeah
that way I think there there are
definitely guys over there I mean you
just want to stay in cover at this point
yeah but the circles can dictate I moved
in a second well this is true you can do
it oh my heart is brace you're good
krusty krab pizza
throw a grenade that always works me
yeah no just pull them out pull out a
grenade and then switch to your weapon
again apparently to show up when you
pull a critic yeah it's too quiet for
there being five other people yeah
they're all just laying down and not
being crazy people so if you gonna mule
do fine right boppity-bop yes engage
each other
is this your tan suede I liked how you
gave up the high grounds to the gear on
the low ground
I wanted the cover clever strategy no
one would ever foresee that or left wait
I hear snippy steps but I'm not gonna
distract you with my stupid ideas I'm
dead what do I know how true that is you
in the circle wait it's kind of there
the guys have to come off the mountain
to get to it oh hey there's a guy
charge him oh wait
Oh Oh God George in there he's coming
behind you he's rushing yeah go for the
guy behind you cuz then you get the low
ground and a little more cover if I
afford it if I had had if I didn't do
the stupid grenade move maybe maybe we
would add that oh you can blame me you
can all blame me oh I'm winded she's
that bad kid I would have been fine
immediately
[Music]